now germany's main political parties
have agreed to increase defense funding
by a hundred billion euros as chancellor
schultz says he wants to modernize the
armed forces germany's military has long
been under finance and poorly equipped
this new deal gets around strict
budgetary rules and helps the government
to meet nato spending goals olaf schultz
says the new funding arrangements will
mean germany will make a greater
contribution to european security
the german bundeswehr will be
strengthened it will be able to fulfill
its defense mission better than ever
before and it will be able to make its
contribution to nato so that we can
defend ourselves against attacks at any
time
well here's dw corresponded leonie von
hammerstein explaining why this hundred
billion euro fund for germany's army is
so significant
yeah it is a pretty significant change
because you mentioned that germany has
spent um infamously little money on its
defense over the last decades much to
the criticism of its nato allies who've
long been demanding that germany meet
its nato obligations and raise its
defense spending above two percent of
its uh gdp and you know bundesbar
officials have been complaining for
years that germany is unable to defend
its country is neglecting the ability to
defend its country and its partners and
there are many stories about how massive
the shortcomings and of the shortage of
combat ready equipment and ammunition
really is a recent report says only 40
of the bundeswear's helicopters are
combat ready and but we also have to
remember the context you know for
decades germany has been extraordinarily
wary of building up its military power
because of its history and because of
the destruction it brought on the
continent and beyond during world war ii
and so that is kind of the context in
which we have to see this change and
olaf choice we heard him there you know
and so this russia's war against ukraine
has basically led to a reckoning of
decades of foreign and defense um policy
and he has now emphasized that germany
needs to be able to defend itself
so this is expected this this is
expected to go to a vote in parliament
on friday is it likely to prove
controversial
well i mean it is and it isn't um so yes
it has been controversially discussed
over the last months um especially you
know within parties especially on the
left side of the political spectrum so
parts of the green party you see
themselves as a pacifist party possible
social democrats and most vocally the
left party um and they have criticized
that as you said it you know this this
extra fund that is now going to be
anchored in the constitution basically
and goes around germany's very strict
fiscal laws and it has said um finds it
hard to explain to voters why a hundred
billion euros can be spent on defense
when other areas of the society also
need urgent investments like
climate and protection like education
like infrastructure so the left has been
sort of vocally opposing this but um
olaf charles needs a two-thirds majority
um to pass this and he has that majority
all of his coalition partners are
backing this and so is the biggest
opposition party in german parliament
and the conservative cdu csu so we are
expecting um the vote to pass this week
okay thank you for that leonie fun
hammerstein